2026 is going to be a crazy ride, guys.
It's going to be wild. I I can't even
fathom what is going to happen this
year, but I think we're going to have
alien disclosure. I think everything is
about to crumble right now. And let's
just get into this. The Epstein files,
what is up with this? I remember uh a
little interview with Trump where he
said the Epstein files weren't even
real, that it was a Democratic hoax.
Check this out.
>> So, this is a Democrat hoax that never
ends. You know, it reminds me a little
of the uh Kennedy situation. We gave him
everything over and over again, more and
more and more, and nobody's ever
satisfied. From what I understand, and I
could check, but from what I understand,
thousands of pages of documents have
been given, but it's really a Democrat
hoax because they're trying to get uh
people to talk about something that's
totally irrelevant to the success that
we've had as a nation since I've been
president. Uh even if you look at DC
right now, DC, it's a totally safe zone.
It's called a safe zone. That's a that's
a term. It's a term of art. Uh it's a
safe zone because it's very safe. You
could walk down the street now and
nothing's going to happen. No crime, no
murders, no nothing because we had a lot
of problems with uh with certain places
and we still do. All run by Democrats or
for the most part run by Democrats. So
what they're trying to do with the
Epstein hoax is get people to talk about
that instead of speaking about the
tremendous success like ending seven
wars. I ended seven wars. Nobody's going
to talk about because they're going to
talk about the Epstein whatever. I
understand that we were subpoenaed to
give files and I understand we've given
thousands of pages of files and I know
that no matter what you do it's going to
keep going. Uh and I think it's I think
really I think it's enough because I
think we should talk about the greatness
of our country and the success that
we're having. I think we're probably
having according to what I read even
from two people in this room we're
having the most successful eight months
of any president ever. And that's what I
want to talk about. That's what we
should be talking about, not the Epstein
hoax.
>> Well, I'm glad he's not prideful. What I
think is interesting is when they had
the P gate stuff. I'm not going to say
certain words, but they said that that
was like a right-wing conspiracy theory.
Rightwing. Now Trump's in office and
it's a Democratic hoax. Do you see the
psychological warfare? Do you see the
manipulation here? Whoever is the face,
whoever is the puppet at the time can
always point the finger and blame it to
the other side. We live in a society of
an illusion of freedom that you actually
get to choose your slave master. You get
to choose your leader. But it's all an
illusion. It's two wings of the same
bird. There there's no difference. It
[clears throat] does your vote doesn't
matter. It doesn't matter who the face
of the president is. Nothing is going to
change. There is an agenda that will
keep on going. It's two steps forward,
one step back. Once one side gets, you
know, ticked off after four years or
eight years of a president, then they
give you your guy and then everybody
settles down and it's this pendulum
swing effect where right before an
uprising happens, then they appease you
and give you your guy and nothing
changes. Abortion's still legal, gay
marriage is still legal, nothing
changes. But see, when Trump came in, he
said, "Oh, I'm going to get rid of the
woke stuff and we're going to, you know,
uh, get rid of some of the toxic
chemicals and food and everybody's just
cheering because normaly is coming
back." But that was the whole plan.
Create chaos so that you can bring in
the order so that you will be praised
when you start bringing in uh
totalitarian systems because the chaos
was so fearful that we'll do anything
for safety.
peace and safety for the whole world.
That's what Trump said. And in his first
day in office, he had the AI guys coming
up and giving a speech about how we're
going to have AI governance. The whole
world is going to be controlled by AI.
Surveillance. People will behave when
they are being surveillanced by AI
governance. This is where all this is
headed, guys. Um uh don't get me
twisted. I am not in any way saying that
the Epstein files are fake, are a
distraction, or a hoax or any of that
stuff. I believe this is 100% real. This
is our president. This is the left and
the right. You got your Republican and
your Democrat. They're hanging out at
the club. They're in the club and you're
not. And that's the problem. That's why
we're in this mess that we're in because
it's a big club.
And the only way that you can be
president is if you're a part of the
club. Don't fall for the whole thing
that Trump is going to save the day that
he's a superhero. He's not. He's just
another puppet. So, this is how Satan
works. He offers you all the kingdoms of
the world, just like he did Jesus. If
you bow down to me, I'll give you all
the kingdoms of the world.
And he's he's giving them that promise.
You see all these American Idols,
they're walking around like gods on
earth while thousands of people are in
the audience raising their hands. I just
want to touch you. I'll never wash this
hand again. And every they have more
money than they could ever spend.
Everywhere they go, things are given to
them. Here's an outfit. Your food is on
that house. You live like a god. When
you sell your soul to Satan, he will
give you all the kingdoms of the world.
But it that road always has a dead end
and he is going to collect at some point
in time. And right now that's what's
happening. Right now all the dirt is
coming out. So these people, these sick
elitist
people have been doing disgusting things
because they have more money than they
know what to do with. And wealthy people
like that, they've done everything in
the world there is to do. And so they're
just experimenting with everything. the
most disgusting, the most vile things.
And actually, that's part of the ritual.
In order to get to that high level, you
must do the most disgusting things
because that's how Satan blesses you.
Because when you partake in sin, you
open the door for Satan to have more
access and power into your life. So, if
Satan wants to offer you power like
sorcery and witchcraft, then you're
going to have to do some disgusting
things to get to that point, right? So,
don't get me twisted on this. The these
things are absolutely true. What's
happening, what's coming out is
absolutely true. But it's because Satan
is done with the puppets. He's done with
the pawns and he's got all the blackmail
and it's all coming out right now. Why
now? Why in just the past few years did
we have the Nickelodeon documentary, the
Diddy Files coming out, the Epstein
files coming out? Uh chaos on every
front. Weather manipulation like never
before.
Everything, every aspect of our society
is falling apart, crumbling. Right? Why?
to bring us to our knees to cry out for
a savior. It's order out of chaos. I'm
getting ahead of myself. We're going to
get into this stuff. Let's let's bring
up some scriptures
because a lot of people think, "Oh, why
do you always talk about conspiracy
theories? Why do you always talk about
the devil? Why don't you just talk about
Jesus?" Do you realize that if you
believe the Bible, you are a conspiracy
theorist? The Bible is the biggest
conspiracy theorist book on earth
because it's all about that we are in a
secret war. A war for your mind. We
cannot see the enemy. He's invisible.
He's a conspirus. He's hiding. And he's
using all these psychological weapons
against us to distract us from Christ,
to make us fall into sin. And it's our
job to expose that deception, to shine
light in the darkness, and to bring
people out of the pit. And maybe our
channel is just a stepping stone for
some. I believe that. Maybe once you see
the light, then you move on and you go
to things that bring hope and
encouragement. And we need that, too.
But we are called to be the watchmen so
that your blood is not on our hands. And
so these scriptures are like conspiracy
theorist scriptures, right? Let no man
deceive you by any means, for that day,
that day meaning the coming of the Lord,
shall not come except there come a
falling away first and that man of sin
be revealed, the son of predition. So,
the antichrist or literally Satan
appearing as Christ, this supernatural
being that's soon to come upon this
world and do lying signs and wonders and
deceive the whole world. That's not
going to happen until something happens
first. A falling away first. Are we
having a falling away?
Our church is lukewarm. Our church is
literally living like the world. Is the
world going into complete chaos and has
uh no moral compass whatsoever?
Do uh concerts look like satanic rituals
on stage? Yes, we are in a falling away
right now. So, what's soon to come? That
man of sin will be revealed and then
Christ returns. We have to understand
pro prophetic events in the order that
they come. Do not fall for
a supernatural being that's doing even
miracles and saying he's Christ. Christ
is not going to set foot on this earth
until everything is done.
Until Satan appears as as Christ is
defeated and then he will set foot. He's
going to come like lightning flashes
from the east to the west. The dead in
Christ shall rise first. Those who are
alive and remain will be called up to
meet the Lord in the air. He's not
coming to us. We are coming. We are
going to him. That's the order of
events. We must understand prophecy. So
let no man deceive you, not even a
pastor who teaches you some false
doctrine, pre-trip, rapture, whatever it
is, until that day come, the falling
away first. We're in a falling away
right now.
And the great dragon was cast out, that
old serpent called the devil and Satan.
So, we're talking about Satan, that old
dragon which deceives the whole world.
It does not say who deceives the lost.
It does not say who deceives the
democrats. It says who deceives the
whole world. That's everyone. He was
cast out into the earth and his angels
were cast out with him. We're talking
about worldwide deception. Worldwide,
not America, not Rome, the world.
And who is doing the deception? Who's
doing the deception?
Satan himself.
He's in control of this world.
For we wrestle not against flesh and
blood. This is not us against Trump, us
against Bill Clinton, us against Bill
Gates. We wrestle not against flesh and
blood, but against principalities,
against powers, against the rulers of
the darkness of this world. So who are
the rulers of the darkness of this
world? The Bible literally tells us that
Satan is the God of this world. He's in
control of everything against spiritual
wickedness in high places. I get
comments all the time from people that
say, "Well, may maybe Charlie Kirk was
actually put there by God, or maybe, you
know, maybe we're actually winning this
time. Maybe Trump is really going to be
our guy this time." No. What does the
Bible say
against the rulers of the darkness of
this world? Satan is the god of this
world. He's controlling the politicians
like puppets. They are pawns in his
game. 1 Timothy 4:1 and2 says, "Now the
spirit expressively says in the latter
times, I believe we're there now. In the
latter times, some will depart from the
faith." Guess what? You can't depart
from something you never had. This isn't
talking about the lost. This is talking
about self-professed Christians who had
the faith, but they departed from the
faith. So, get rid of the whole once-s
saved, always saved mentality. Salvation
is a relationship. It's not some magic
prayer that you said one time when you
were 9 years old and you're locked in no
matter what you do. It's about clinging
to Christ daily, walking the way he did,
picking up your cross daily, enduring
until the end, and you will receive a
crown of life.
But what is there to endure if it's a
once- saved always say? Well, I I said
the little prayer. I'm good to go. Some
will depart from the faith. Why? Giving
heed to deceiving spirits and doctrines
of demons.
So, we're talking about in the latter
times, people who are Christian, who are
founded on the Bible, and I believe in
Jesus, and I'm an all-American
Christian, they're going to depart from
the faith because of something that's
coming upon the world.
We wrestle not against flesh and blood,
but there's going to be deceiving
spirits and doctrines of demons.
Remember this. Put these pieces
together. There's going to be the rulers
of the darkness of this world.
Demons are ruling this world. And
they're going to deceive the entire
world. The dragon's going to deceive the
entire world. And it's going to make
Christians depart from the faith because
they're going to give heed to these
seducing spirits like Eve in the garden.
When that serpent seduced her and said,
"This fruit will make you wise. You will
never die. Your eyes will be open.
You'll be like God." That is deception.
That is deceiving. That is seductive
even to a Christian. Right?
And then it says in Matthew 24:24, "For
there shall arise false Christ." So
don't put your trust in somebody. Oh,
well, they talk about Jesus. I don't
care. Um, the Mormons talk about Jesus,
the Jehovah's Witness talk about Jesus,
the Newagers talk about Jesus, the
Buddhists talk about Jesus. Is it just
if you just talk about Jesus, then
you're trustworthy? No. Look at how many
pastors and evangelists who ended up
coming out and saying, "I'm gay," or, "I
had I committed adultery." Look at
Michael Tate from the News Boys. what
was going on with him for 20 years was
doing drugs, alcohol, and messing around
with women and men.
And he's a professed Christian, knows
all the right things to say, all the
terminology in the songs, in the
interviews. He can speak like a
Christian through and through. And yet,
he's living a double life.
Stop falling for just because they said
they're a Christian that they truly are.
What does Jesus say? You will know them
by their fruits, by how they act. It's
not about what you proclaim or that you
carry a Bible, go to church every week,
and can quote scripture.
It's about how what is your fruit
saying. This is how you identify a tree.
Right? When a trees are all dead, it's
really hard, if not impossible, to know
what kind of tree it is until you see
the fruit.
And it continues and it says, "And false
prophets shall show great signs and
wonders in so much that if it were
possible, they shall deceive the very
elect." I believe this elect is way
smaller than we think. We think, "Oh,
elect, a Christian. I'm a Christian. I'm
not going to be deceived." Well, what do
we read back here? It said that some are
going to depart from the faith. So
clearly, not just all Christianity is
going to be safe, right? Some are going
to depart from the faith from these
deceiving spirits.
And they're going to be false Christ and
false prophets. People that say all the
right things on stage, on TV, and all
that. They do not have the fruits of a
Christian. They're lying deceivers. And
they're going to be able to show great
signs and wonders. If it were possible,
they shall deceive the very elect. We
are going to face a time very soon where
supernatural beings are going to do
signs, wonders, and miracles. Are we
ready to face that head on and not fall
for it?
Revelation 13:13 and 14 says, "And he
doeth great wonders, so that he maketh
fire come down from heaven in the earth
on the earth in the sight of men, and
deceiveth them that dwell on the earth
by means of those miracles which he had
power to do in the sight of the beast."
So why is why is the whole world
deceived by the devil? We just read the
dragon will deceive the entire world.
That some will depart from the faith,
giving heed to seducing spirits.
And we know that the rulers of the world
is
not flesh and blood, but satanic forces.
And why are they going to be deceived?
By means of those miracles. So, I've
heard so many people think that if if a
miracle happens, it has to be from God,
right? If a healing happens, it's got to
be from God. If a prophecy actually
comes true, it's got to be from God.
That's not true. That we're talking
about deception here, not outright lies.
Deception. Satan has power like we've
never seen before. Something that's
going to deceive the entire world.
Chloe's really into this right now.
[laughter]
The whole world is going to be deceived
by satanic forces doing lying signs and
wonders and miracles. Think about that.
Keep that in your mind. Okay?
The signs that we're looking for for how
the antichrist or Satan appearing as
Christ is going to come, he's not coming
when the world is in peace, in harmony.
It's going to happen when nations are
fractured, trust and institutions are
shattered, morality is confused, people
are emotionally exhausted,
justice systems appear corrupt or
broken, and the public is desperate for
order, peace, and rescue.
This is this is where everything is
headed right now. This is why there are
the worst disasters, the quote unquote
natural disasters that we've ever
experienced.
This is why all the stuff's coming out
about Nickelodeon and and P. Diddy and
Epstein. Remember, you only know what
you know because the controlled media is
allowed to tell you.
You only get to hear what they want you
to believe. And you can call me a crazy
conspiracy theorist, but what you can
never accuse me of is believing or
trusting the government and the media.
And I'll say it over and over and over
till my face turns blue. Do not trust
the government. When was the government
ever trustworthy? Pharaoh, Stalin,
Hitler. When was it ever trustworthy?
Why are we putting our trust in man? And
why should we trust the media that's
controlled by three corporations? who
control everything. It's all scripted.
It's all propaganda. And the majority of
these events are false flags and not
even true. To manipulate you, to control
your emotions, to divide us,
to divide and conquer, to create order
out of chaos, to instill fear in you so
that you can be controlled,
that you will be under their foot. So
that is what's happening right now. all
these points emotionally exhausted. I'm
feeling it. I'm feeling like some days
it's just hard to get started in the
morning. The deception works because
people are primed emotionally, not
because they are intellectually
convinced. When fear, outrage, and
despair peak, discernment drops.
People are not going to be thinking
rationally anymore. They're just so
desperate, so exhausted that when they
are offered a solution that sounds good,
they're going to take it without
discernment. Think about that. We are
all primed right now. We're all
emotionally exhausted and we're looking
for some kind of peace. What if a
supernatural being appeared doing lying
signs and wonders and miracles?
We're at a place where we're not even
going to use our discernment anymore.
This has to be Christ. I've never seen
anything like this in my entire life.
I've never seen a a spiritual being of
light doing great things like healing
people and ending COVID and ending
pandemics and ending wars and ending uh
crazy climate change
and natural disasters, right? We've
never experienced like anything like
that ever. And if we don't understand
the Bible, we're going to fall for it
hook, line, and sinker. Without a doubt,
hands down. Why wouldn't you?
Why would you not trust this being of
light that's literally doing great
things, peace, and miracles? Because we
understand prophetic events. We
understand that Satan is coming first as
a deceiver to deceive the world into
worshiping him, and then Christ is going
to return. Deception doesn't need to be
perfect. It only needs to feel
relieving. This is how it works. Order
out a chaos. Cause the chaos. Bring
about the solution. And the people will
be ready to take it up. Be ready to
accept it.
Divide and conquer. This is a strategy
that appears clearly in the art of war
and the book propaganda. This strategy
has been used by communists for
centuries.
And this is how it works. split the
population into moral tribes. Give each
side a sense of righteousness, but
ensure that neither side sees the full
system. So, right now we have some
political things going on where one side
says, "Ah, we don't like this." And the
other side says, "You're crazy. We need
this. This is our protection." So, think
about ICE. You have the the liberal left
saying defund ICE and we want immigrants
and all this stuff and you got the right
saying you're crazy. If we just open up
our borders, a bunch of people are going
to come in. And so they're dividing.
They divided us with with something
that's been going on for years and we've
never divided and had these protests
over it before. Everything was just
going about fine. there was certain uh
systems of getting into our country and
we knew there was illegal immigrants and
and it wasn't causing chaos until the TV
told you to. The TV said, "Go outside
and protest. Fight your neighbor. Your
neighbor is your enemy."
It's programming.
Once people identify emotionally with a
side, they will defend lies if those
lies serve their identity. So it doesn't
even there's no more rational thinking,
right? It's just like the crazy part is
is no matter who's the face of the
president, they can be saying the same
thing and suddenly the So here's a prime
example. Um,
when Biden was in, everybody was like,
well, when Biden was in, the right was
anti- shots, anti- Bill Gates and all
this stuff. Anti- the AI stuff. And then
Trump comes in and what does he do? He's
doing the same stuff. He's literally
sitting at a table with Bill Gates,
still pushing for for vaccines, still
pushing for AI. nothing changes, but
suddenly it's okay because it's coming
from Trump. You're going to accept it as
long as your guy is up there. You're
going to accept the agenda because you
feel emotionally attached to your side.
Now,
so as long as the elites can keep you
from seeing the whole system that both
wings are the or two wings of the same
bird, then they win. They divide us
against each other and they they don't
have to do anything. and they just sit
back and watch. One scandal outrages
side A. Another scandal outrages side B.
Both ignore what what implicates the
entire structure that they the elites
and Satan ultimately are behind the
whole thing.
So you got this red versus blue. we're
against each other and you got one side
we support ICE and you got the other
side saying abolish ICE and we're taking
a stand for something because we all
innately want to stand for something. We
want to be a part of something. We want
to do something that that brings
righteousness into the world,
but we're deceived about what it is
because it's meant to be deceptive. It's
meant to divide us.
And so here's a prime example of how
both sides are the same side. When Kamla
Harris was running, she had Megan the
Stallion
uh at her campaign twerking with a bunch
of girls throwing up the horns and we're
like that's crazy. Like who would ever
vote for that? Obviously this is
wickedness and disgusting, right? And
then we get Trump and what's going on?
Oh Nicki Minaj. Do you know there's no
difference in Megan the Stallion and
Nicki Minaj? Literally no difference.
They're like both strippers and
prostitutes and and uh nasty rappers who
rap together.
Like they are the same person. And yet
whether you have Trump or Kamla,
two wings of the same bird. There's no
difference.
They are two wings of the same Masonic
bird. And here you see Trump sitting at
the table with Zuckerberg and Bill
Gates.
So what how do people get so distracted
and so they lose all discernment and and
don't even realize that Trump has the
same agenda as Biden and Obama and
George Bush and it's all the new world
order agenda.
Chloe, I don't know what to do with you,
girl.
Please lay down.
So you see, same agenda. No matter who's
in office,
order out of chaos as uh talked about in
morals and dogma. Create or allow
crisis. Amplify emotional instability.
Expose corruption selectively like we
see now with a bunch of redacted files.
And even though there's thousands of
thousands, you're only getting to see a
little piece, right? Whatever they want
you to see. Let trust collapse.
Introduce a stabilizing authority. So,
this is where we're at right now. The
collapse of society. They're only
showing you what they want you to
believe, what they want you to see. And
right now, we are losing trust in
everything. It's 100% collapse. We can't
trust the Christian musicians that we
were singing five years ago. We found
out that they're drug addicts and
homosexuals and uh adulterers and
fornicators. So, we can't trust the the
Christian musicians. We can't trust
uh the people we looked up to in in the
church world and the evangelical world
because Ravi Zachcharias was committing
adultery and Perry Stone and all these
bigname preachers are committing
adultery. So we've lost hope in the
church.
We've
uh Hollywood's been exposed. All the
people that we looked up to and
idolized, now we're finding out how
disgusting they are.
And now everyone that rules, all the
rulers of the world are being exposed
for who they truly are, the disgusting
filth that they truly are. And what
where do we put our hope? Where do we
put our hope? All hope is lost. The
whole structure has collapsed. And we
are primed and ready for Satan to appear
as the cosmic savior
as aliens from another world or
whatever, however he's going to do it,
and perform lying signs and wonders. And
we are not going to discern anything.
All that's going to go out the window
like, "Wait a minute. Wasn't isn't it
Satan that comes first and he's going to
do a lot of good things uh to deceive
the world?" No, we're going to say this
has to be Christ because Satan is big
and scary and can only produce fear and
death, right? So if he's doing anything
good, it's got to be Christ. That is
wrong. That mentality. You have to
change that mentality. He's a He's a
angel of light who wants to give you
knowledge, right? The chaos is
engineered and it's about to be quote
unquote fixed. This is scripture, guys.
I know it sounds sci-fi,
but in Revelation 16:13-4, it says, "I
saw three unclean spirits like frogs,
for they are the spirits of devils
working miracles." Which go, remember,
we already heard about this, right? The
miracle working demons are going to
deceive the entire world and even cause
some who are in the faith to depart from
the faith because they're giving heed to
seducing spirits.
These frog devils,
they're going forth to who? The kings of
the earth, the rulers of this world. We
just saw that the rulers of this world
are are satanic agencies
and the whole world to gather them to
the battle of the great day of God
Almighty. We're going through this
collapse right now and we're all
emotionally exhausted. We can't put our
hope and faith in anything except
Christ. And suddenly a majestic
supernatural being that we've never
experienced before is going to appear
and is going to promise peace and
actually do miracles and is going to
deceive many. How are we going to stand
in this day?
We can only do it if we understand
prophecy. If we are in the word of God
every day understanding the line of
events. And this is why Satan tries to
distract us. He he tries to keep us out
of the word of God at any cost. Oh,
don't you want to play that video game?
Oh, don't you want to uh watch the
football game? Don't you want to listen
to music all day? Don't you want to be
distracted, distracted, distracted, and
out of the word of God so that he can
actually deceive the world? But pretty
soon, when we are faced with this, we're
going to have to rethink everything.
Even if you really truly understood the
Bible, suddenly you're going to be like,
"Wait a minute. Who am I to think that
Jesus is the only way?
Do I think that these Buddhists, these
kind newagers, and all these people
aren't going to make it? We're all just
trying to get to the same God. We just
have different paths to get there.
You're going to start questioning
everything. Unless you're founded,
planted on the rock. Unless your house
is built on the rock, you will be swept
away by the great deception that's about
to happen. I believe it's happening this
year.
I'm not a date setter. I'm not a
prophet, but I believe 2026 is the year
of full disclosure, and all this chaos
that's happening right now is only
solidifying that point.
Alice Bailey
uh an oultist
wrote about this in a book called the
externalization of the hierarchy and she
was talking about in the year 2025 that
there was going to be an externalization
of the hierarchy details
the emergence of a spiritual hierarchy
of masters into physical manifestation.
a process requiring human humanity
to align its motives with the soul. It
explores the plan for humanity's
evolution, including the anticipated
reappearance of the Christ
and the strengthening of spiritual
non-physical influences on world
affairs. So, this is how deceptive the
enemy is. Even newagers believe in
Christ. They want to reach Christ
consciousness. He's one of our ascended
masters. We're we're longing for his
return. Muslims are waiting for Christ
to return. Newagers are waiting for
Christ to return. Raens
who believe that aliens created us are
waiting for Christ to return.
So when Satan appears as Christ, he's
going to deceive many, many people
because they're not reading the Bible.
They don't have the prophetic outline.
They're going by this garbage
where it says the externalization
process. The book explains that the
hierarchy's manifestation is a gradual
staged process rather than an overnight
event aimed at guiding humanity toward
deeper spiritual understanding. I'm glad
it said that because I think too many
times we we hear a message like this and
we're like, I've been hearing that for 5
years. I haven't seen anything. It's
gradual
human free will. The book emphasizes
that while the hierarchy offers
guidance, they cannot interfere with
human free will, making the outcome
dependent upon human choice. So look at
that. I just talked about this in the
CERN episode.
Satan has to follow the rules. He can
only do what God allows him to do. So,
Satan and his demons cannot come into
your life unless you give him some kind
of open door. And there are many, many
doors to do that. Are you drinking
alcohol? Are you smoking marijuana? Are
you taking pharmaceuticals? Are you
doing yoga? Do you have a, you know, a a
little Buddha statue? Or did you bring
back something from that Africa trip?
There are so many things that we just
don't understand that are giving Satan a
foothold into our life. Imagine when you
are on the brink of insanity, emotional
exhaustion, and you're looking for any
type of savior to give you some relief.
That's when Satan says, "All right,
they're inviting me. They want anyone.
They're not putting they're not putting
their hope in Christ anymore. They want
anyone to come save them, and I'll be
their savior." It says, "Significance of
the festivals." I think this is
interesting. This is the first time I've
read this. It details the importance of
the three major spiritual festivals.
Easter being one of them because it's
not a Christian holiday. It's a pagan
holiday. Wesock. I didn't know what that
was till I looked it up. It's uh a
celebration of Buddha and the Christ.
Maybe that's Christmas. I'm not sure. As
times of height heightened energy. See,
these days that many Christians keep,
such as Easter and Christmas, are not
Christian whatsoever. And the dates that
they're on are have significance,
importance to pagan gods and fertility
and all this stuff. And it's not the day
that Christ was born. It's not the day
that Jesus resurrected because that
would be a date, right? That wouldn't be
some random moving Sunday in April.
That's all about the equinox and things
like that and the moon. It's based on
the moon. Why would Christ's
resurrection be celebrated based on the
moon on a shifting date? It doesn't make
sense. And and see, Satan has tricked us
all into keeping pagan holidays and
pagan traditions, which gives him
another foothold into our lives. Now, I
want to talk about Raianism.
There's this guy and yeah, there's only
40,000 to 100,000 members of this cult,
but these people believe that Christ is
going to return and he's an alien. And
look what it says. So, what I'm getting
at is this is a mentality that many
people are going to have because
remember the dragon's going to deceive
the entire world. And so when how are
you going to deceive Buddhists, Muslims,
Christians, atheists who don't even
believe in anything spiritual, anything
paranormal or supernatural? Well, you're
going to come as a visitor from a far
far distant galaxy, just like Roger
Morno said. So when Satan appears in a
spaceship and saying he comes from a far
distant galaxy and he looks like Christ
and he's doing the things that Christ
would do like heal and do signs and
wonders, then we're going to have to
rethink everything. Wait a minute. When
he rose from the dead and levitated back
into the sky, he must have went back to
his mother's ship and he's been in space
this whole time and he's come back.
And and you might laugh at that idea,
but what if you were face to face with
it? We've never faced anything like
this. People are going to start
rethinking everything.
And so their understanding is the Raian
movement founded by Claude Ver Varilhon
in 1974
interprets the return of Christ through
a nons supernatural scientific lens
viewing it as a as the anticipated
return of an extraterrestrial race known
as the Elohim. See how biblical it
sounds? This is why new age is so
deceptive because it uses all this
biblical language like Christ
consciousness and u I don't know just
you have to read these books you will
see that they use scripture in these new
age books
the Elohim as creators where aliens
believe that life on earth was
scientifically created by an advanced
extraterrestrial civilization called the
Elohim who were mistaken for gods by
ancient humans.
the return of Christ. Rather than a
spiritual resurrection, alens expect the
Elohim to return to Earth, bringing back
with them the great prophets of
humanity, including Jesus, Buddha, and
Muhammad, among others. Like this is
really syncing up with some things that
I believe that are going to happen. I
believe that we are going to start
seeing the externalization of the
hierarchy. these gods that you know like
Chris Bledsoe, a self-professed
Christian
um who had an alien encounter believes
that these beings are good angels simply
because they healed him of Crohn's
disease. But what does the Bible say?
Line signs and wonders, miracle working
demons. He didn't use discernment and he
said, "Well, they healed me. They must
be good. These alien grays are good
angels." and he actually has an a
reoccurring visitation from Hathor, the
lady he calls her, and he believes that
she's the Holy Spirit. And when you look
into Hatheror, it's a it's a Egyptian
goddess, but you can see the merging of
the paganism and the Christianity
because of he had he has these
experiences face to face and he has to
rationalize it. And he and he's
thinking, well, maybe the Egyptians
um they thought she was Hatheror and the
the Babylonians, they thought it was
this God and but we think of it as the
Holy Spirit. But it's really all the
same deity. We just have different ways
of interpreting just like the Pope said.
The Pope Francis before he died said all
religions are different ways to God. We
just it's like different languages that
we speak.
I believe that mentality is going to be
accepted when we start seeing these
things. Now, I want to read um a passage
from the book Marinatha. This was
written by Ellen White. You guys might
totally unsubscribe just because I'm
reading the writings of a woman in the
1800s who loved God and had prophetic
visions and wrote these books. But
listen to this. The world is a theater.
The actors, its inhabitants. I believe
this one 100%. are preparing to act
their part in the last great drama with
the great masses of mankind. There is no
unity. That's where we're at now. No
unity except as men confederate
to accomplish their selfish purposes. So
talking about these elite who are
banding together for their selfish
purposes. God is looking on. His
purposes in regard to his rebellious
subjects will be fulfilled. The world
has not been given into the hands of
men, though God is permitting the
elements of confusion and disorder to
bear sway for a season. That's where
we're at right now. God is permitting
this because of free will. A power from
beneath is working to bring about the
last great scene in the drama. Satan
coming as Christ and working with all
deceivleness and unrighteousness. And
those who are binding themselves
together in secret societies.
Those who are yielding to the passion of
uh for confederation are working out the
plans of the enemy. The cause will be
followed by the effect. Transgression
has almost reached its limit. Confusion
fills the the world. That's where we're
at now. Confusion fills the world and a
great terror is soon to come upon human
beings. The end is very near. We who
know the truth should be preparing for
what is soon to break upon the world as
an overwhelming surprise.
I believe this 100%. I mean, everything
she said was perfectly to a tea where
we're at today that God is allowing this
chaos to happen, this rebellion to
happen, this confusion to happen, and
people are binding themselves in secret
societies to uh bring about Satan's plan
to appear as Christ, bringing peace and
safety. a false sense of peace and
safety and unity, a religion based on
coexist and tolerance. And we all
worship the same God. So if you are a
true follower of Christ and you believe
the Ten Commandments, you will be the
you'll be public enemy number one
because automatically you're a bigot for
thinking that your way is the only way.
If you believe that Jesus is the way and
not a way, you're the problem. If you
believe that this lifestyle is sinful,
but yet we see it as love, you're the
problem.
Only Christians will be the ones who
will be separated from society. Who will
reject the one world religion because
it'll look so good. It'll deceive, if it
were possible, the very elect. But it
will deceive some Christians. It will
deceive some people who were in the
faith, but they will give heed to
seducing spirits and doctrines of
demons, and they will depart from the
faith because what is coming will look
so good to us when we have went through
this chaos and we're looking for any
form of peace whatsoever, any kind of
relief, and we see something that looks
like miracles, peace, safety.
Many people are going to fall for this.
The only way we will not fall for this
deception
is to be in God's word every day.
Putting on the full arm of God, praying
spiritual warfare, prayers, uh casting
Satan out of our lives through the power
of prayer and and the power of God's
word because that is the sword of the
spirit. If you guys like this video,
please give a thumbs up. It really helps
this video get out into the algorithm.
If your eyes were open in some kind of
way, please tell me in the comments
section if you agree, if you disagree,
where you think all this is headed. I do
believe that the Epstein files are real.
I do believe all this disgusting stuff
is true because Satan is now done with
his pawns. And he's about to come and
set foot on the earth as the master and
ruler of this world. And the only way we
are not going to fall for it is to
understand that Satan is appearing
first. And he's not going to come with
horns and a pitchfork trying to kill
everyone. He's going to unite the world
in a false system of worship because any
worship that is not true worship, we
must worship God in spirit and in truth.
Any worship that's not true worship is
worship to Satan. So he's going to
deceive the entire world if we are not
grounded on the truth. If you guys want
to support this ministry, you can do so
by going to candidtruth.org. We got Cash
App, Vimmozel, PayPal. We even got
Patreon. And if you guys have been
given, we love you. We thank you so
much. We cannot do this without you.
We're 100% donor supported. We do go to
churches and events and schools and and
give presentations and you can book us
on our website. If you like t-shirts and
hoodies and mugs, we got those things on
our website, too. And we get five around
five bucks on everything that sells. And
that really helps support this ministry.
Please subscribe to this channel. Share
this with all your family and friends.
We love you. We thank you. We cannot do
this without you.